well it's taking a while but we're now
in the final 48 hours before a
confirmation vote for judge Brett
Kavanaugh and at this hour there's still
a number of key votes ahead for the
latest on where we stand we're joined
now by Fox News reporter Gillian Turner
and Gillian what else can you tell us so
Laura tonight all eyes remain laser
focused on the key Republican swing
votes that's Holland Murkowski and flake
so far Collins and flake Pope spoke
positively about the FBI report but
Murkowski says she needs more time
something in short supply for the
pressure cooker that is Capitol Hill
tonight this process has been ruled by
fear and anger and underhanded
gamesmanship for too long time vows to
stand up to this kind of fact hi Jackie
I am angry I own it but earlier tonight
a new wrench in the plan senator steve
gaines republican of montana said he
wouldn't be available on Saturday at any
point even if there was a vote for
Cavanaugh who he strongly supports James
was slated to be in Montana walking his
daughter down the aisle originally his
office told Fox News with the fluid
timing of the FBI report release they
couldn't avoid a potential schedule
conflict but Fox News can confirm he
spoke tonight directly with Brett
Kavanaugh his office says he has made
arrangements to be there to get him
across the finish line as needed
now without Danes on the hill for that
vote the math would have been critical
for McConnell he'd have needed every
single one of the 50 remaining
Republicans to vote yes that advant
flake Murkowski and collins or two of
those three plus Manchin now the Senate
slated to convene tomorrow morning at
9:30 and by rule this triggers the
procedural vote at 10:30 if the Senate
invoked cloture at 11:00 they then got
30 hours max until the confirmation vote
if they take all of that 30 hours this
puts us at about 5:00 p.m. Laura on
Saturday for the vote yeah all right you
covering the protests tomorrow yeah all
right I'm gonna give you my bike helmet
thank you need to wear a bike helmet and
some type of like protective gear good
luck today tomorrow with the protesters